On the right, there are three different detox programs.
Could you explain them?
Would I get similar benefits as if I were doing detox supplements if I were to do the programs?
Good question.
So the different detox programs that are on the right, but if you search, there's lots of detox programs on the right.
And there's different detox frequencies in your overnight program.
So there are what's different about them?
What's different different frequencies that have been discovered that will help the liver or help the kidneys with detox?
Now different people will feel like certain programs work better for them than others.
They feel better. They'd run XYZ program.
And they don't feel the same when they run a different program.
You're just going to have to experiment with those.
Are they similar as doing a detox supplement?
Yes, but it's different.
So a detox supplement may be specifically supporting a certain pathway from a nutritional standpoint.
You're using frequencies to support different pathways.
I always think it's better if you can just use frequencies.
It's quicker.
You don't have to purchase a product.
If you're taking a product, even a great herbal product, let's say it has to go into your stomach and into your testicle tract,
and then you have to absorb it and it's a circulator on the blood and get to the area that you're trying to affect.
So if you could just use frequencies, it's better.
So I always think the rife should be your first go to.
I have to say that you shouldn't do detox supplements or do supplements for different things.
Say, if you have an infection or something, I'd always say at least get started on the rife immediately.
So if I got a sore throat, run the sore throat program.
If you have symptoms of something, at least be running the rife right away.
I mean, you shouldn't do other things, but they can be coupled together and you could even get better results.